so many
bills
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich welcome back to the channel
if you're new here on this channel we
talk about technology and architecture
so if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below and let's get on with
today's video today we're talking about
starting up your own architectural
practice and how much
does it actually cost in 2020
so this video idea actually came to me
thanks to one of my tutors back in the
day
they instructed us to create a fake
business
and to do all the financial reports
required to start that business
so i thought it would be a good idea to
go back and reflect on that
documentation
and actually see how close i was back in
the day
versus to now when i've been in the
industry for a little while now
so straight off the bat without making
you guys wait too long
my original estimate for starting a
practice
was 54 498
australian dollars now that was
considering a four-person partnership
agreement
and starting a medium-sized company with
four architects involved
that was a pretty big stab in the dark
if i was to scale that number back to a
sole practice
single occupancy version it would
actually equate to about
thirty three thousand five hundred and
twenty eight dollars
so from the start back in the day when i
did all my research and thought i knew
everything
about running a business and being in
the profession
i originally thought it would cost 33
000 australian dollars
to start a sole trader business in the
architecture industry
now again i've been in the industry for
a while now i know what i need and what
i don't need
so i thought it'd be a good idea to go
back take a look at these numbers
and really give you guys an insight on
what it actually costs
to start an architectural practice in
2020 so i'll put up some sort of side by
side
graph here to really encapsulate what i
was thinking before and what the reality
of it
is now so if you're going to start a new
practice in 2020 chances are you're
probably going to be starting at home
with covert going on around the world
still the chances are probably a lot
higher that you're going to be starting
it from home than ever before
so in reality and in the past i
estimated
50 per week to start a practice out of
your home office which is a very
accurate representation
in the market right now originally i
estimated a five and a half
thousand dollar per annum technology and
computer cost
now speaking from experience this is a
huge overkill
realistically if you don't have a
computer and you don't have a desktop
set up ready to go
you're probably going to be spending
about three and a half thousand dollars
to get the machine up and running and
you're probably gonna have to upgrade it
every three to five years
so talking just initial startup costs
we're talking
three and a half thousand not five and a
half thousand being in the architecture
profession
you tend to do a lot of printing however
as technology progresses we're doing
less and less of that so our original
estimate
was two hundred dollars a year for
printing and maintenance
now speaking in 2020 it's probably still
about 200
a year because we try and print less and
less every single day
and just provide clients with digital
documentation
this is not only better for the
environment but also better for the
business bank account now this is where
the naive graduate in me came out to
play
i originally budgeted two thousand
dollars for a drone
seven hundred dollars for modeling
material
and then thousands and thousands of
dollars for different programs
that i don't actually need all of them
so i originally planned to run
revit rhino autodesk v-ray
the whole adobe suite and the list goes
on
but now in reality i don't actually need
to run
all those programs to run a successful
firm nor
do you in practice so for example we can
scratch off the two thousand dollar
drone and the seven hundred dollars in
modeling fees
because in reality you're not going to
be need to take drone photos
to run a successful practice they are
good for marketing material but they're
definitely
not required and 700 in model making
material
unless you're a truly avid model maker
it is not a good idea to be going and
spending this much money on model making
material
especially considering clients aren't
going to be paying you for 40 50 hours
to spend
and make a physical model of their
project this is usually done out of
their own goodwill of your heart
and to run a successful practice you
probably
aren't going to be doing something like
this so we can scratch that off list
completely when it comes to programs
you're more than likely only going to be
running
one program be it either archicad or
revit
for me personally i'm well experienced
in archicad so that would be
my platform of choice if i was to go out
and do this again in 2020
a big shout out to michael cook who
dropped a comment on one of my videos a
few days ago
outlining how much graphisoft charged
him
in 2020 for an archicad perpetual
license
they quoted him 11 746 dollars
plus gst and then an additional 76
dollars
per annum plus gst for ongoing
maintenance and upgrade fees
so that's an 11 and a half thousand
dollar bill that you have to flip
up front day one now if michael's great
comment doesn't deserve a like and
subscribe on this channel i don't know
what does
but it would truly be appreciated if you
hit that like button help this video
with the algorithm
and smash that subscribe button to let
me know that you're enjoying these
videos and want me to create
content just like this however based on
all the other programs that i spoke
about previously you don't need all of
them
so straight away we can get rid of
everything that was on the list
the only thing that really and truly
does have to remain
is the adobe suite you're going to be
using photoshop indesign
illustrator and of course acrobat reader
pro
all the time so this is definitely a
worthwhile investment if for example you
did want to go to revit instead of
archicad
your upfront costs are a lot cheaper
it's only three thousand four hundred
and ten australian dollars
per year to get started with revit so
straight away you're saving yourself
seven eight thousand dollars from the
get go but over a five six year period
archicad is definitely going to be the
cheaper licensing option
so i guess that's more or less a
budgeting and a financial question you
need to ask yourself
when starting a new practice do you have
the ability to play the long game
and wait this out five years to save
yourself that money or
do you really only have one or two years
to test this idea to see if it's
worthwhile
if that is the case and it is successful
which i truly do hope it is for you
then revit might actually be one of your
biggest and most expensive costs
financially every single year per staff
member
moving on to a practice management side
of things originally i estimated a
thousand dollars
for a platform called coincraft now
coincraft is still going in 2020 but
i've
never actually ever used it instead i
use a platform called
pro workflow and it costs about 20
australian dollars per month
so instead of my original estimate of
one thousand dollars
it only cost 240 dollars for a systems
management
system in 2020. i originally estimated
that i'd be using the nat spec
australian standards
for 340 per annum but in reality you end
up writing your own specifications in
practice
so this charge is completely null and
void some fees that are
actually unavoidable that you have to
pay every single year recurring
is a 35 abn registration number
renewal a 38 business name renewal
an architect's fee which if you are a
registered architect want to be part of
a registered institution
you don't have to be it is good to be
yeah long story short it's good to be
that's about a thousand and eighty
dollars every year
and then you have your ongoing fees of
websites and marketing
so originally i estimated 150 a year for
websites
in reality that's probably about double
at about 300 dollars if you're doing it
yourself
and then on top of that i put 5200 for
marketing
which still in this day and age is
probably an appropriate amount
of a marketing budget to be running a
hundred dollar weekly campaign
if you know what you're doing on
facebook advertising instagram ads
and things like that so there are two
insurances that you're going to need to
start a professional architectural
practice in 2020
be it an architect's firm or a drafting
agency both of these
require the same indemnity insurances so
you're going to need
professional indemnity insurance and
public indemnity insurance
public indemnity insurance was
originally estimated at about a thousand
dollars
which is still accurate today in 2020
whilst professional indemnity insurance
for a one million dollar cap
was estimated at eighteen hundred
dollars this is a pretty accurate
representation considering that now
in 2020 it is only about 2 100
so not a huge jump between my original
estimate and what it costs now
however the difference being is
realistically a 1 million dollar cap
is quite low in the architectural
industry you probably want to be going
for about two million as a minimum
which bumps you up to about 2 900
australian dollars per year
as a starting point with no claims no
pre-existing conditions etc
again if you're doing bigger practices
bigger projects commercial projects
that 2 million might turn into 10 might
turn into 20
so that category is almost never ending
finally for some reason the naive and
young david
decided to put in fifty dollars per
client meeting eighty dollars for design
packages
and three hundred and eighty dollars
annually for accounting fees
now i'm not entirely sure why i'd be
spending fifty dollars per
client meeting considering that most
client meetings are done in your office
face-to-face talking about their project
design packages i'm not even sure what
originally i was planning with an
80 design package and apparently i was
only planning on having five client
meetings a year which realistically it's
about 500
so that is definitely underestimate if
that was an actual cost so thankfully 50
per client meeting is not a thing
accounting fees on the other hand is
something
you can or you don't have to pay it's up
to you
so for me i can manage everything
through excel at this point in time
but having something like a my orb or a
quickbooks or a xero
is definitely a good program platform
that is worth
investing the money in so i've left that
on the list at 380
per year so overall let's go back to
what i originally thought my
total cost for a sole practice sole
trader would be
that was 33 528
in reality to start an architectural
firm in 2020
with archicad as your primary software
is going to cost you
28 993
dollars if on the other hand you want to
run revit first of all instead of
archicad
that's going to drop all the way down to
20
657 australian dollars
so overall if i was running an arcade
platform i wasn't too far off the mark i
was about
five thousand dollars overestimating how
much it would cost to run an
architectural practice
if i was running a revit i was so far
over i almost doubled it so there you
have it guys if you were to start a
brand new architectural practice
in australia running the bare bones of
it it will cost you anywhere from 20 to
30
000 australian dollars i know many
people are always ambitious and curious
to start their own business
but keep in mind that there are a lot of
costs that come with it
so take this decision very seriously
plan it out
and if you do make the leap i wish you
all the best
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below to help this video
with the algorithm
and if you want to see more of my
content smash that subscribe button down
there
and as always i'll see you next monday